[Music]
the bad house might be one of the most
popular Nickelodeon shows at the moment
but it definitely wasn't an easy road to
get there wait until you hear how the
show drew inspiration from one of the
most underappreciated things ever don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's check out the 10 shows that
inspired the loud house SpongeBob
SquarePants
if you've been watching our channel for
a while you probably know about all the
hidden references this show makes to pop
culture music movies and more but it
looks like the show did want to pay a
tribute to SpongeBob SquarePants and we
can only assume it's because Chris
Savino the creator of the loud house got
inspired by spongebob when creating this
awesome show we can definitely see
several similarities between spongebob
and the loud house especially since both
shows are pretty wacky must feel pretty
awesome to feel inspired by a top
Nickelodeon show and then manage
defeated in ratings
maybe that's why you could find the
Spongebob references in the loud house
the team probably thought it was better
to pay a tribute you know just in case
their show ends up beating spongebob and
it most definitely did but we're sure
there's no bad blood between the
creators of the lattice and the team
behind spongebob anyways so it's safe to
say all these references are most likely
just a tribute to one of the most
popular Nickelodeon shows ever
peanuts it's not a secret that the loud
house's inspiration does also come from
peanuts no not the nuts the characters
that started off as the comics and soon
became a popular franchise with TV shows
movies and much more you can find plenty
of peanuts references in the actual show
but Chris Savino also talks about the
process of creating the loud house and
confirms that peanuts was indeed an
inspiration for creating the loud house
although the original peanuts were much
more evenly paced Chris decided to spice
things up because kids these days need
more brain stimulation and a fast-paced
environment when it comes to watching
cartoons but it's not just the actual
show it's also the characters in it the
strong and funny characters from the
loud house are just absolutely perfect
and can make you laugh just as much as
the Peanuts characters can if you think
about it the loud house does indeed have
that relaxed Sunday feel to the show so
the team behind it definitely succeeded
in their mission rocky and bullwinkle
unless you're into old-school 60s
cartoons you
we have no idea who rocky and bullwinkle
are rocky and his friends is one of the
most progressive and absolutely
hilarious 1960 shows that still is
beloved to this day the series focuses
on The Adventures of a flying squirrel
called rocky and a slightly dim witted
moose named Bullwinkle this show was so
successful it also featured a series
called rocky and his friends as of 2018
the series has actually been revived on
Amazon and it's featuring a popular
cartoon voice actress Tara Strong but
you can frequently find the names Rocky
and Bullwinkle mentioned in pop culture
it was a show that Chris Savino grew up
watching as a child although he didn't
understand that cartoon making could
actually be a real-life job Rocky and
Bullwinkle along with several other
cartoon characters and shows we'll talk
about in a moment actually later
inspired Chris into the world of
animation you can also find a minor
Rocky and Bullwinkle reference in the
loud house episode called come sail away
the moose hockey player toy actually
resembles Bullwinkle Popeye speaking of
shows that Chris Savino watched when he
was a child
Popeye was also one of them who could
possibly forget about this spinach
eating character that managed to become
one of the most iconic cartoon
characters ever Popeye was also a show
that was frequently present in Chris
savino's life and he did mention it as
one of the inspirations for getting him
into the world of animation we can
definitely see how the craziness of the
loud house and Popeye connect do you
remember the loud house episode where
they get visited by the exterminator
because of Lincoln's pet spider if you
pay close attention to how he looks
you'll notice that the character pretty
much resembles Bluto from Popeye
Bluto was a large character and Popeyes
main antagonist and although the
exterminator wasn't really the main
antagonist of the loud house it was
clear that Lincoln didn't really agree
with the reason why he was there it
could very well be a coincidence
but considering Popeye was one of the
shows Chris Savino loved to watch we
have a feeling the exterminators
character really was inspired by the big
and muscular Bluto Charlie Brown we
already know Chris Tavano got inspired
by peanuts but we also have to
separately mention Charlie Brown because
the character had such a massive impact
on today's TV world Charlie Brown
references can be found just about
anywhere and it's all we used to watch
on TV Chris Tavano shares the same love
for Charlie Brown and if you paid close
attention to this
you probably noticed some pretty sneaky
references which could be interpreted as
a tribute for example in changing the
baby you can see Lincoln takes Lily to
the clothing store but pay attention to
the back of the scene because he'll
notice two shirts resembling the typical
Charlie Brown shirt we thought this was
just a coincidence but in the title card
of the serial offender episode you can
see the same yellow color and the black
pattern on the bowl a Charlie Brown
moment can also be seen in homespun
where we see mr. loud trying to fix the
TV antenna a scene similar to a Charlie
Brown Christmas
intro appears on the screen the loud
house definitely did a good job of
paying tribute to the show that inspired
this amazing cartoon Ren & Stimpy the
loud house wasn't as inspired by
Nickelodeon cartoon such as spongebob
Chris Savino actually managed to get his
first job on the Ren & Stimpy show in
case you're not familiar with it the Ren
& Stimpy show is a popular 90s cartoon
and one of the first original
Nickelodeon shows the series focuses on
The Adventures of the main characters
Rin and emotionally unstable Chihuahua
and Stimpy a happy-go-lucky cat it was
by far one of the most popular cartoons
if you grew up in the 90s but did you
know that Chris Savino was actually
responsible for the layout of Ren &
Stimpy
and although Ren and Stimpy references
aren't present in the LAT house as of
yet you can find plenty of fan fictions
as well as fan art of the two worlds
colliding we can definitely see how the
crazy story lines and the defined
characters of the loud house would
connect with this iconic Ren & Stimpy
show
Rocko's Modern Life we can also thank
Rocko's Modern Life for inspiring the
loud house Chris Savino had some pretty
impressive projects under his belt
before he created his own show and
Rocko's Modern Life is one of them you
can definitely tell that the loud house
wasn't just a one-hit wonder and the
animation process took a long time to
develop Chris was actually the creator
and prop designer from season 1 to
season 3 so you can actually thanked him
for creating such awesome and quirky
characters we're pretty sure we'd get
inspired by Rocko and wants to create
more exciting things after working on
such an awesome show in fact even some
of the show's comedic elements like
innuendos can be compared to the loud
house you can actually find the two
worlds merging in plenty of fan art and
fan fictions fans have actually plenty
of requests for the loud house
crossovers but Nickelodeon shows like
Rocko's Modern Life are probably the
most popular if you think about it it
wouldn't be that hard to bring the two
together considering they both come from
Nickelodeon Dexter's Laboratory
you probably remember Dexter the child
genius working in his laboratory while
his sister DeeDee tried to ruin
everything he ever worked on christina
was responsible for creating the
storyboard for season 3 and season 4 of
Dexter's Laboratory and while many
people didn't seem to enjoy those
particular seasons it's safe to say that
Dexter inspired the loud house have you
ever noticed the similarities between
Dexter and Lisa both are child geniuses
always working in the lab and absolutely
no one else in the family understands
what they're doing in fact they also
kind of look similar both never really
smile they're both short they're
insanely smart kind of crazy and they
almost have the same type of glasses
when Lisa is in her lab clothes she
definitely looks like Dexter fans of
Dexter's Laboratory have been comparing
Dexter and Lisa since the launch of the
loud house and you can definitely see
some similarities we can definitely
imagine Lisa as the female version of
Dexter especially since Chris Savino
actually worked on Dexter's Laboratory
we can't blame the fans wanting to see
this crossover seeing Lisa and Dexter
together would be adorable the Powerpuff
Girls here's another surprise you
probably didn't know unless you
religiously follow the world of animated
cartoons did you know that Chris Savino
worked on several episodes from multiple
seasons of one of the most beloved 90
shows the Powerpuff Girls he was the
director and story boarder which means
he was pretty much in charge of the
whole thing while fans of animated
cartoons weren't exactly impressed with
the execution of these two seasons it's
safe to say that the Powerpuff Girls did
serve as an inspiration for the lab
house the show is extremely colorful and
the colors even represent each of the
characters personalities considering
most of the loud house characters come
with a typical look and the same strong
and sometimes crazy personalities it's
safe to say Chris used the same concept
when he decided to create the loud house
and besides who knows if nickelodeon
would ever even approve of the loud
house without seeing chris's previous
work on all these Cartoon Network and
Nickelodeon shows unfortunately you
can't find any of the Powerpuff Girls
references on the loud house just yet to
keep your eyes peeled in the possible
future for shout outs because we have a
feeling they will happen newspaper
comics although they didn't start off as
TV shows many newspaper comics became
extremely successful shows
entered the world of animation in fact
some of the most iconic comic books
frequently get revived rebooted and
turned into actual cartoons Chris Savino
is never shy to mention that he owes his
animation career to newspaper comics
we've seen the connections without house
has with peanuts and Charlie Brown and
these are the comics and shows Kristen
joined as a child but it's not just
peanuts if you've paid attention to some
of the details in the loud house you'll
notice that the show also pays a tribute
to a comic called ctrl + Alt + delete
which is responsible for creating one of
the longest memes on the internet pay
attention to Lunas room and you'll
notice a poster on the top right corner
of the walls it's an extremely
simplified version of the popular
control-alt-delete comic called las
Chris Savino also frequently mentioned
how much he'd absolutely loved to own
his own comic book strip and who knows
maybe that'll be his next adventure and
his comic will be turned into a popular
show and that's all for our video do you
like the loud house let us know in the
comments thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]